we suspected it for the last two days
and Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell is now admitting that
Republicans do not yet have the votes to
successfully block impeachment witnesses
in the Senate trial of Donald Trump now
yet is a key word remember that in the
past we've seen reports that Mitch
McConnell didn't have the votes to
confirm Brett Kavanaugh to the Supreme
Court Brett Kavanaugh is now on the
Supreme Court so any time we hear from
Mitch McConnell that he doesn't yet have
the votes we have to understand that
that may be a game that he's playing the
latest word is that witness related
votes are going to happen on Friday in
the Senate McConnell says hopefully by
then they will have the votes
remember that Witnesses are dependent on
a simple majority in the Senate so you
don't need two-thirds you need just 51
senators to say we want witnesses that
would be the 45 Democrats two
independent senators angus King and
Bernie Sanders and four Republicans we
suspect that Mitt Romney and Susan
Collins might be two of those four
Republicans new reports suggest there
could be many more Republicans planning
to vote for witnesses but until they do
it we don't know and as I said yesterday
Republicans are remarkably unreliable at
doing the right thing so let's not
speculate any further let's focus on the
facts and the reality of a trial and
witnesses trials should have witnesses
75% of the country wants witnesses per a
new Quinnipiac poll which we are linking
to Republicans have complained that they
have not seen any firsthand testimony of
what Donald Trump did and wanted to have
done Donald Trump's former national
security adviser John Bolton is willing
to testify and is likely to say what he
says in his upcoming book which is Trump
told him to withhold aid to Ukraine
until Ukraine smears Joe Biden publicly
that's a first-hand witness he's willing
to testify Republicans claim they want
firsthand witnesses but they are trying
to block john bolton from testifying
Republicans started signaling their
talking points to argue against
witnesses a few days ago there are three
main talking points Republicans are
using number one they've started saying
well after we do 64 hours of stuff 24
hours of house manager
twenty-four hours of trumps lawyers
sixteen hours of senator questions then
we can decide if we really need to hear
more and the implication is it's all
kind of the same right 24 hours of Adam
Schiff is the same as hearing from John
Bolton it's just more hours of course
this is part of the gaslighting because
John Bolton can actually tell us what
Donald Trump did this is incorrect
it's gaslighting but they're going to
try it secondly they are trying a
strategy of if Democrats get witnesses
when we get witnesses to because this
can't just be one-sided now the
determination about who testifies
shouldn't be about the party affiliation
or which side wants the witness the
question should be are they material
witnesses Republicans have signaled that
if john bolton testifies they might want
joe biden to testify they might want
hunter Biden to testify
this is gaslighting the Biden's have
nothing to do with determining the guilt
or innocence of Donald Trump Republicans
want to make it about Joe Biden but it's
not Bolton is a first-hand witness to
what Donald Trump did Trump is on trial
not Joe Biden so that's the second
gaslighting strategy they will try
number three Republicans will say
Democrats could have called these
witnesses when they had hearings in the
house they don't get to do it now now of
course that's illegally and historically
invalid you don't have to call every
witness in the house the same that you
don't have to call every witness in a
grand jury that you eventually call in
the trial the Senate is a valid place to
call witnesses they had the option of
subpoenaing john bolton in the house it
could have taken a year or longer for
that subpoena to work its way through
the judiciary and nothing would have
happened so that is a misdirection those
are the three most common arguments that
we're hearing from Republicans against
hearing from witnesses last thought let
me go back to the beginning Mitch
McConnell says they don't yet have the
votes to block witnesses he has said
this before and gotten the votes this
could be a ploy to make it look like
they're really deliberating Republicans
are really taking it seriously and
really thinking through do they want to
have witnesses and if so which one and
then when they say no on Friday if they
don't get the votes they can say it
wasn't a foregone conclusion we took all
week to
deliberate we thought about it really
hard we didn't think we had the votes
and in the end we did so I will believe
that for Republicans are going to vote
for witnesses when four Republicans vote
for witnesses in the Senate which may
happen on Friday tell me what you think
will happen will John Bolton ultimately
testify remember a Sunday is my birthday
we are doing a huge membership special
on Sunday February 2nd if you want to be
notified of this membership discount
which will be a beautiful thing we've
looked at it very strongly a lot of
people don't know about it but we're
doing it again on our mailing list at
david pakman.com you put in your email
address sunday you'll get an email with
instructions on how to take advantage of
this great membership special do you
feel like you just don't have enough
time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that they're just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
nonfiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about eight bucks a month but you can
try it for free for a week and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to
blankest comm slash Pakman what blinka
studs is take thousands of popular
non-fiction books and condense them into
either text or audio that you can read
or listen to in just 15 minutes and what
you get is all of the most important
ideas and information from the book
imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
catch and kill by Ronan Farrow super
interesting book probably already
familiar to some in my audience and a
really interesting take at how Harvey
Weinstein and his alleged transgressions
were brought to light excellent
investigative piece Blinky's has totally
transformed how I consume information I
love it of course I read a book in its
entirety when I can but there are simply
just so many books that I want to read
and would not have the time for if it
weren't for bling cast they have books
on politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week
and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent
then blink astiz for you